This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Tomorrow night, 15,000 cheering fans will pack Madison Square Garden in New York City to witness a giant basketball double header. In that cheering crowd, sitting in row C, C-11 will be a modest 77-year-old man. Those fans won't know that he made possible the games they're watching. But you're going to meet him now. That tape is from an old New York radio show called We The People. The guest is James Naysmith. A hundred and twenty-five years ago in 1891, Naysmith was a PE instructor at a small
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。明晚，15000名欢呼雀跃的球迷将挤满纽约麦迪逊广场花园，观看一场盛大的篮球双赛。在那欢呼的人群中，坐在C区11排的，将是一位谦逊的77岁老人。那些球迷不会知道，正是他让这些比赛成为可能。但你现在就要见到他了。那段录音来自一个名为《我们人民》的纽约老牌广播节目。嘉宾是詹姆斯·奈史密斯。125年前的1891年，奈史密斯是马萨诸塞州斯普林菲尔德一所小型
college in Springfield, Massachusetts when a particularly bad snowstorm struck. For days the students couldn't go outdoors, so they began rough housing in the halls. We tried everything to keep them quiet. Something had to be done. One day I had an idea. I called the boys to the gym, divided them up into teams of nine,
学院的体育老师，当时一场特别严重的暴风雪来袭。学生们好几天都不能去户外，于是他们开始在走廊里打闹。我们尝试了一切办法让他们安静下来。必须得做点什么。有一天我灵机一动。我把孩子们叫到体育馆，把他们分成九人一组，
and gave them an old soccer ball. I showed them two peach baskets I'd nailed up with each end of the gym. I told them the idea was to throw the ball into the opposing team's peach basket. A lot of sports don't have such a definitive point of origin, but this one does. I blew a whistle and the first game of basketball began. That day in 1891 James Nasemith invented basketball. And what rules did you have for your new game, Dr. Nasemith? Well, I didn't have enough, and that's where I made my big mistake. The boys began tacking, kicking and punching in the clinch. They ended up in a free for all in the middle of the gym floor.
给了他们一个旧足球。我向他们展示了两个我钉在体育馆两端的桃篮。我告诉他们，这个想法就是把球投进对方球队的桃篮里。很多运动都没有如此明确的起源，但篮球有。我吹响了哨子，第一场篮球赛开始了。1891年的那一天，詹姆斯·奈史密斯发明了篮球。那么，奈史密斯博士，你为你的新游戏制定了什么规则吗？嗯，我制定的不够多，这就是我犯大错的地方。孩子们开始在争抢中拉扯、踢踹和挥拳。最后他们在体育馆地板中央打成了一团。
In subsequent weeks, Nase Smith would go on to make more rules for the game. Some of those are still around today. Like the one that says players can't run while holding the ball. They have to dribble it. But there was one thing, not so much a rule, but a design decision that he made back in 1891 that continues to define the way the game has played. He had to decide how high to hang the Peach Basket. That's Kerry Champion. She's an anchor at ESPN and host of the Be Honest Podcast and she's going to help us tell our story today. Nase Smith chose to hang the Peach Basket at 10 feet above the court floor. There was a running track that went around the court at that level, but otherwise the decision
在随后的几周里，奈史密斯继续为这项运动制定了更多规则。其中一些至今仍在使用。比如那条规定球员持球时不能跑动，必须运球。但有一件事，与其说是规则，不如说是一个设计决定，他在1891年做出的这个决定至今仍在定义这项运动的比赛方式。他必须决定把桃篮挂多高。那是凯莉·钱皮恩。她是ESPN的主播，也是《Be Honest》播客的主持人，她今天将协助我们讲述这个故事。奈史密斯选择将桃篮挂在离球场地面10英尺高的地方。当时那个高度有一条环绕球场的跑道，但除此之外，这个决定
was pretty random and just a little higher or a little lower and everything would be different. That arbitrary decision to put the basket at 10 feet caused the game of basketball to take shape around the tallest players, but it happened gradually. In fact, in the beginning, the game was played by shorter, less imposing players. In the very early days of the game, people didn't really have a conception of height, having really any importance to the game. That's writer and journalist Andrew Heisel. So a lot of the high scores in the very early days,
相当随意，只要再高一点或低一点，一切都会不同。那个将篮筐设在10英尺高的随意决定，使得篮球运动逐渐围绕着身材最高的球员成型，但这发生得很缓慢。事实上，起初这项运动是由身材较矮、不那么魁梧的球员进行的。在比赛的早期，人们并没有真正意识到身高对比赛有什么重要性。那是作家兼记者安德鲁·海塞尔。所以早期很多高分，
were guys who were like six foot tall. It was not until a few decades in that team started recruiting really tall guys. And at the time, they were sort of referred to often as goons. Nowadays, if you play a little rough or dirty, you might be called a goon. Back then, Big Men were sometimes called goons just because they were big. The first so-called goon to have a major impact on the game was a big white dude named George Micon,
都是由大约六英尺高的人创造的。直到几十年后，球队才开始招募真正高大的球员。当时，他们通常被称为“暴徒”（goons）。如今，如果你打球有点粗野或肮脏，你可能会被称为“暴徒”。那时，大个子有时被称为“暴徒”，仅仅因为他们个子大。第一个对比赛产生重大影响的所谓“暴徒”是一个名叫乔治·麦肯的白人大个子，
who played for the Minneapolis Lakers from 1948 to 1956. He was a six foot ten monster who wore big round spectacles when he played. Mikean towered over his opponents and broke scoring records with his strength and accuracy. George Mican forces his way through the center spins and shoots and is followed by a ball of his opponents and broke scoring records with his strength and accuracy. Mike and with such a force they actually had to change some rules in the game to offset his advantage. For example, the rule against goal-tending came about because of Mikan. Goaltending is the act of catching or batting away another player's shot as the ball is on a downward path toward the basket. Mikan was so tall he could just stand under the basket and swat away shots by the other team. Goaltending was banned in 1945.
他从1948年到1956年为明尼阿波利斯湖人队效力。他是一个六英尺十英寸的怪物，打球时戴着一副大圆眼镜。麦肯在对手面前高高在上，凭借力量和准确性打破了得分纪录。乔治·麦肯强行穿过中路旋转投篮，随后被对手包围，他凭借力量和准确性打破了得分纪录。麦肯的力量如此之大，以至于他们不得不改变比赛的一些规则来抵消他的优势。例如，禁止干扰球的规则就是因为麦肯而产生的。干扰球是指在球向篮筐下落的过程中，接住或拍掉对方球员投出的球的行为。麦肯太高了，他可以直接站在篮下拍掉对方球队的投篮。干扰球在1945年被禁止。
But rule changes didn't stop George Mikan or his fellow big Man from dominating defensively and offensively. You started to see people saying like it's too easy to score. Like they were really sort of disgusted. They thought this should be a triumph to get the ball in the hoop, not something that happens 100 some times a game. The ease with which these super tall players could put the ball in the basket was alarming people. The traditionalists didn't like the way the game was going, but they had no idea what was about to hit them.
但规则的改变并没有阻止乔治·麦肯或他的大个子同僚在防守和进攻上的统治地位。你开始听到人们说，得分太容易了。他们真的感到很厌恶。他们认为把球投进篮筐应该是一种成就，而不是一场比赛发生100多次的事情。这些超高球员把球投进篮筐的轻松程度让人们感到担忧。传统主义者不喜欢比赛的发展方向，但他们不知道接下来会发生什么。
The Dunk. Sometimes called the slam dunk. The first one in an organized game happened in 1936, but dunking didn't really get going in basketball until the 1960s. And man, the traditionalist, they hate it the dunk. But not just because it was a new, unconventional way to put the ball in the basket. The dunk became political. The key year is 1966. That's Matt Andrews. My name is Matt Andrews.
扣篮。有时被称为“灌篮”。第一次在正式比赛中出现是在1936年，但扣篮直到20世纪60年代才真正流行起来。天哪，传统主义者，他们讨厌扣篮。不仅仅因为它是一种将球投进篮筐的新颖、非传统的方式。扣篮变得政治化了。关键年份是1966年。那是马特·安德鲁斯。我叫马特·安德鲁斯。
I teach American History at UNC Chapel Hill and I have a particular focus on sport and society. So it was in 1966. In the NCAA Championship game, Texas Western, with an all black starting five, easily defeat Adolf Rupp's all white University of Kentucky team. This win by Texas Western against Kentucky was a big deal in the college basketball world. Kentucky was one of the last major college teams in the country that still didn't have any black players. The coach of Kentucky was a guy named Adolf Rupp, many viewed him as a racist.
我在北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校教授美国历史，我特别关注体育与社会。所以那是在1966年。在NCAA锦标赛决赛中，德克萨斯西部大学凭借全黑人首发阵容，轻松击败了阿道夫·鲁普执教的全白人肯塔基大学队。德克萨斯西部大学战胜肯塔基大学在大学篮球界是一件大事。肯塔基大学是全国最后一批没有黑人球员的主要大学球队之一。肯塔基大学的教练是一个叫阿道夫·鲁普的人，许多人认为他是个种族主义者。
According to the sports correspondent Frank DeFord, who was in the Kentucky locker room that night, the language Rupp used against the Texas Western players sent a chill down his spine. And there was this moment right at the beginning of the game where Texas Western's David Latin gets the ball and makes a move toward the hoop. The defender in front of him is Pat Riley. He go on to win nine NBA titles as a player, coach and executive and Latin flies over him. Riley's like six foot four, stockly both, and Latin just rises above him and slams the ball through the hoop. Texas' victory and Latin's dunk were seen as direct challenges to the establishment.
据当晚在肯塔基更衣室的体育记者弗兰克·德福德说，鲁普对德克萨斯西部大学球员使用的语言让他不寒而栗。比赛刚开始时，德克萨斯西部大学的大卫·拉廷拿到球，向篮筐移动。挡在他面前的防守者是帕特·莱利。他后来作为球员、教练和高管赢得了九个NBA总冠军，而拉廷从他头上飞过。莱利身高约六英尺四英寸，身材魁梧，但拉廷就在他上方升起，将球扣进篮筐。德克萨斯的胜利和拉廷的扣篮被视为对建制派的直接挑战。
After all, this was 1966. There was a lot going on in America. The Black Panthers have become a visible force. In Oakland, the Panthers had armed and organized themselves to protect their communities from brutal racist police. And many white Americans were worried a revolution was about to take place. Black Power was this new, evocative phrase. So that the failure to pass a civil rights bill isn't because of black power, isn't because of the student nonviolent court.
毕竟，那是1966年。美国发生了很多事情。黑豹党已经成为一股可见的力量。在奥克兰，黑豹党武装并组织起来，保护他们的社区免受残酷的种族主义警察的侵害。许多美国白人担心一场革命即将发生。“黑人权力”（Black Power）是一个新的、令人回味的短语。所以民权法案未能通过并不是因为黑人权力，也不是因为学生非暴力协调委员会。
What's so interesting about this phrase is it's lack of specificity, knowing is exactly sure what black power means. Into this context comes the dunk, and the dunk seems to be black power manifest on the basketball court. The dunk is physical, the dunk is forceful. You know, when you lay the ball in, you're laying the ball in, but when you dunk, you're doing it to someone. And at a time, when so many white Americans are uneasy with the specter of black violence. The dunk becomes suspect. Then to scare people like Adolf Rupp even more comes a player called Lou Alcender.
这个短语最有趣的地方在于它的缺乏具体性，没人确切知道“黑人权力”意味着什么。在这种背景下，扣篮出现了，扣篮似乎是篮球场上黑人权力的体现。扣篮是身体上的，扣篮是有力的。你知道，当你上篮时，你只是把球放进去，但当你扣篮时，你是在对某人施压。在许多美国白人对黑人暴力的幽灵感到不安的时候，扣篮变得令人怀疑。然后，为了让像阿道夫·鲁普这样的人更加害怕，一个名叫卢·阿尔辛多（Lou Alcindor）的球员出现了。
He would later change his name to Karim Abduljbar and become one of the most exciting and famous players in the history of the game. But in 1967 he was a young man, 7 feet 2 inches tall, and already tearing in the history of the game. But in 1967 he was a young man, seven feet, two inches tall, and already tearing up the college game with his vicious dunks and fast movement. House senders surrounded by white shirts, unstoppable. So the NCAA, that's the National Collegiate Athletic Association, made a decision.
他后来改名为卡里姆·阿卜杜勒-贾巴尔，成为篮球史上最令人兴奋和著名的球员之一。但在1967年，他还是一个年轻人，身高7英尺2英寸，已经在大学比赛中以他凶猛的扣篮和快速的移动大杀四方。阿尔辛多被白人球员包围，势不可挡。于是NCAA，即全国大学体育协会，做出了一个决定。
The only way to stop this guy was to get rid of the thing he did best, the slam dunk. In 1967, they banned the dunk. And for 10 years, there's no dunking in college basketball. Lou Elcender, aka Kreme Abdul Jabbar, was not happy about this. In fact, he explicitly said that the only reason for the ban was because they were scared that black guys like him were going to take over the game, although he used much stronger words. Regardless, the slam dunk was done, and college basketball was sent back in time for 10 years. Basketball was in a bad place. The NCAA administrators
阻止这个家伙的唯一方法就是废除他最擅长的东西——扣篮。1967年，他们禁止了扣篮。在接下来的10年里，大学篮球比赛中没有扣篮。卢·阿尔辛多，也就是卡里姆·阿卜杜勒-贾巴尔，对此并不高兴。事实上，他明确表示，禁令的唯一原因是因为他们害怕像他这样的黑人会接管比赛，尽管他用了更强烈的词汇。无论如何，扣篮被禁止了，大学篮球倒退了10年。篮球处于一个糟糕的境地。NCAA的管理者们
had made an arguably racist decision to ban the slam dunk. Meanwhile, in the professional league, the NBA, players could still dunk, but fans were losing interest. Here's Andrew Heisel again. This is for the NBA, considered like the low point of the league. There are all of these pieces written about how the game is dying and nobody wants to watch it. And there's all these questions about why. Nase Smith's original accidental design decision
做出了一个可以说带有种族主义色彩的决定，禁止了扣篮。与此同时，在职业联赛NBA中，球员仍然可以扣篮，但球迷们正在失去兴趣。这是安德鲁·海塞尔。这对NBA来说被认为是联赛的低谷。有许多文章写道比赛是如何走向死亡的，没人想看。关于原因也有很多疑问。奈史密斯最初偶然的设计决定
to put the basket at 10 feet had inadvertently given us this beautiful and exciting slam dunk, but it had also caused the professional game to revolve too much around these super tall players. The game had gotten jammed up around the net. People weren't passing as much. They just hand the ball to the giant guy and he'd stand under the basket, trying to put it in.
将篮筐设在10英尺高，无意中给了我们美丽而令人兴奋的扣篮，但也导致职业比赛过多地围绕这些超高球员展开。比赛在篮筐周围陷入了僵局。人们传球少了。他们只是把球交给那个巨人，他站在篮下试图把球投进去。
This had the effect of slowing down the play, and that slowness was draining the game of its excitement. Basketball needed a design solution. People suggested a lot of fixes. No backboard, a convex backboard, a smaller basket, a bigger ball, a smaller ball, a no scoring zone around the basket, and even a height cap. Another group of coaches called for the hoop to be raised to 12 feet.
这导致比赛节奏变慢，这种缓慢消耗了比赛的兴奋感。篮球需要一个设计解决方案。人们提出了很多补救措施。没有篮板、凸面篮板、更小的篮筐、更大的球、更小的球、篮下禁区，甚至身高限制。另一组教练呼吁将篮筐提高到12英尺。
None of those changes caught on. And then, this guy comes along. Well, we feel that those people who are not under a contract to a lot of litigation, if they like to take a look at us, we would. So remember George Mican, the original NBA Goon 6-foot ten inches tall with big round specs. Well, in 1967 he was working as a travel agent in Minnesota where he used to play. When he gets a call from a couple of guys asking if he wants to head up a new professional basketball league that would compete with the NBA.
这些改变都没有流行起来。然后，这个人出现了。好吧，我们觉得那些没有受到诉讼合同约束的人，如果他们想看看我们，我们会……所以还记得乔治·麦肯吗？最初的NBA“暴徒”，身高6英尺10英寸，戴着大圆眼镜。好吧，1967年，他在明尼苏达州担任旅行社职员，那是他曾经打球的地方。当他接到几个人的电话，问他是否想领导一个新的职业篮球联盟来与NBA竞争时。
What do his old NBA friends have to say about his new job. Good luck, baby. I mean, it really was just sort of making up that you go along. It was simply what's getting an idea. And let's see what we can do here. That's Terry Pluto who wrote a book about the founding of this new league. They called it the ABA, the American Basketball Association. And George Mike and became its first commissioner. They were trying everything to get fans reengaged in the game.
他的NBA老朋友对他的新工作有什么看法？祝你好运，宝贝。我的意思是，这真的只是边走边编。这仅仅是一个想法。让我们看看我们能在这里做什么。那是特里·普鲁托，他写了一本关于这个新联盟成立的书。他们称之为ABA，即美国篮球协会。乔治·麦肯成为了它的第一任专员。他们尝试了一切办法让球迷重新参与到比赛中来。
Sometimes they featured cow-moaking contests for entertainment. And one halftime show in Indiana involved a wrestling bear called Victor. Beautiful brown bear who looks to me that he weighs at least 500 pounds. Most of their ideas didn't stick. A lot of times good ideas are like that. They're one of 12 things that people stuck to the wall and out of the 12. One became really good, one helped a little bit, and the other 10 were almost embarrassing. In this case, one of the ideas was really good. In fact, it's the design solution that arguably saved basketball, and the secret star of this story that we're telling right now.
有时他们以挤奶比赛作为娱乐。印第安纳州的一场中场秀涉及一只名叫维克多的摔跤熊。美丽的棕熊，在我看来它至少有500磅重。他们的大多数想法都没有坚持下来。很多时候好的想法就是这样。它们是人们贴在墙上的12件事之一，在这12件事中，一件变得非常好，一件有一点帮助，而其他10件几乎令人尴尬。在这种情况下，其中一个想法非常好。事实上，它就是可以说拯救了篮球的设计方案，也是我们现在讲述的这个故事的秘密明星。
The three point shot. Fire in for three, kicks a three, fur is in, and he hits a three. He's one, knocks down. The flutters and knocks it down for three. So all you sports fans know this, but originally shots from the field were all worth two points. But the ABA's innovation, which they actually borrowed from an earlier defunct week, was to draw an arch line about 22 feet away from the basket, and any shot made from behind that line was now worth three points. The ABA was trying to please the fans.
三分球。三分命中，投进三分，球进了，他投中了一个三分。他投中了，投进了。三分球投进。所以所有的体育迷都知道这一点，但最初的投篮都只值两分。但ABA的创新，他们实际上是从一个更早倒闭的联盟借来的，就是画一条距离篮筐约22英尺的弧线，任何从那条线后投出的球现在都值三分。ABA试图取悦球迷。
Fans get excited when they see a three-pointer, but they can also go and practice the shot at home. It's more egalitarian. That's Ramona Shelburn, senior writer for ESPN.com. It's the sense that if I practice hard enough, I don't have to be the most athletic guy in the court. I don't have to be an incredible dunker. It's something that when fans watch it,
球迷看到三分球会很兴奋，但他们也可以在家里练习这种投篮。它更平等。那是ESPN.com的资深作家拉蒙娜·谢尔本。这是一种感觉，如果我练习得足够刻苦，我不必成为球场上最有运动天赋的人。我不必成为一个不可思议的扣篮手。当球迷观看时，
they think, oh, I could do that too. In 1976, the NBA merged with the ABA, and three years later, they brought in the three-point shot. At first, it was about pleasing the fans, but they slowly came to realize something about the three-point shot. When you'd study it, if you shoot 35% on three-pointers, and you shoot 45% on two pointers, if you just break it
他们会想，哦，我也可以做到。1976年，NBA与ABA合并，三年后，他们引入了三分球。起初，这是为了取悦球迷，但他们慢慢意识到关于三分球的一些事情。当你研究它时，如果你三分球命中率是35%，而两分球命中率是45%，如果你把它
down, it makes so much more sense to build a team around three point shooting because you're going to score more points and that's the point of the game. And now some teams have decided that the way to win is to concentrate on three point shots. When the NBA first introduced the three-point shot, games featured only a couple of three-point attempts. This season, it's more than 10 times that. And if there's any team that's demonstrating the value
拆解开来，围绕三分投篮建立一支球队更有意义，因为你会得到更多的分数，而这正是比赛的目的。现在一些球队已经决定，获胜的方法是专注于三分球。当NBA首次引入三分球时，比赛中只有几次三分尝试。本赛季，这个数字是那时的10倍多。如果有哪支球队正在展示价值
of the three-point shot right now, it's the Golden State Warriors from California and Mr. Steph Curry. Curry for the league! Curry, what's the deepest behind the back? Curry for the league. Curry, what's the deepest behind the back? Fire's a train. How are we going to put it in?
三分球的价值，那就是来自加州的金州勇士队和斯蒂芬·库里先生。库里为了联盟！库里，最深处的背后运球？库里为了联盟。库里，最深处的背后运球？投出一个三分。我们要怎么把它投进去？
If you don't know who Steph Curry is, he's about 6 foot 3, so he's short by NBA standards. But this hasn't stopped him from being the star of the team and of the whole NBA. I think every kid growing up in America now is trying to be Steph Curry. He is skinny and doesn't seem to have anything physically dominant about him, and yet when you watch him play, he's electric. Curry can hit three pointers for Golden State from really anywhere he likes, which makes it hard to defend against him and balances the influence of the big men. Because if there are guys like Curry who can score from anywhere, then the 7-foot guys have to move away from the basket,
如果你不知道斯蒂芬·库里是谁，他身高约6英尺3英寸，所以按NBA标准来说他很矮。但这并没有阻止他成为球队和整个NBA的明星。我认为现在在美国长大的每个孩子都在努力成为斯蒂芬·库里。他很瘦，看起来没有任何身体上的统治力，然而当你看着他打球时，他是充满活力的。库里可以为金州勇士队从他喜欢的任何地方投中三分球，这使得防守他变得困难，并平衡了大个子的影响力。因为如果有像库里这样可以从任何地方得分的人，那么7英尺高的球员就必须离开篮筐，
where they're most useful, to defend. And once you allow players to score an extra point from shooting further out, the game spreads out. You get a whole new game. The game has changed for the better. There's no doubt about it. That's former Indiana Pacer Jerry Harkness. Harkness was a player in the NBA and the ABA. Because the game is exciting. The game is running shoot, quickness, defense, opening the game up, making it more aggressive. But even though the three-point shot has had a balancing influence, some traditionalists
他们最有用武之地的地方，去进行防守。一旦你允许球员从更远的地方投篮获得额外的一分，比赛就会散开。你会得到一场全新的比赛。比赛变得更好了。毫无疑问。那是前印第安纳步行者队球员杰里·哈克尼斯。哈克尼斯是NBA和ABA的球员。因为比赛很刺激。比赛是跑轰、敏捷、防守，打开局面，让比赛更具侵略性。但尽管三分球产生了一种平衡的影响，一些传统主义者
still don't like it. And I think it's basketball. I think it's like a circus sort of thing. Why don't we have a five point shot and a seven point shot? Where does it stop? That's sort of thing. But that's just me, that's just old school. That San Antonio Spurs coach Greg Popovich speaking to ESPN about Steph Curry's golden state
仍然不喜欢它。我认为这是篮球。我认为这就像马戏团一样。为什么我们不设五分球和七分球？在哪里停止？就是那种东西。但这只是我，这只是老派。那是圣安东尼奥马刺队教练格雷格·波波维奇去年在接受ESPN采访时谈到斯蒂芬·库里的金州
warriors last year. What Popovich is saying kind of echoes what people said about the dump 50 years ago. That it's a trick, a departure from the fundamentals of basketball. And I kind of agree with Coach Pop. But even Popovich seems to think that the three point shot is here to stay. So a certain degree, you better embrace it, you're going to lose. And every time we've won a championship, three point shot was a big part of it. shot is here to stay. Instead of designing the beautiful, powerful dunk out of the game, we designed a counterbalance,
勇士队时说的话。波波维奇所说的有点呼应了50年前人们对扣篮的评价。那是一个噱头，背离了篮球的基本功。我有点同意波波教练的观点。但即使是波波维奇似乎也认为三分球将长期存在。所以某种程度上，你最好拥抱它，否则你会输。每次我们赢得冠军，三分球都是其中很大的一部分。三分球将长期存在。我们没有把美丽、强力的扣篮设计出局，而是设计了一个平衡物，
the three point shot, and now the game is more inclusive than it's ever been. You've got these little guys that can shoot bombs from anywhere on the court, and they're still room for the big guys close in. The three pointer and the dunk have become the Yin and Yang of basketball. All of this has sort of been by accident. The 10-foot tall basket, the dunk, the three-point shot. But then again, the game wasn't carefully designed in the first place. Really it came about because all James and Ace Smith wanted was to stop some rowdy kids from getting into too much trouble. And the whole thing started with a couple of peach baskets I put up in a little gym 48
三分球，现在比赛比以往任何时候都更具包容性。你有这些可以从球场任何地方投出炸弹的小个子球员，大个子球员在内线仍然有空间。三分球和扣篮已经成为篮球的阴阳。所有这一切在某种程度上都是偶然的。10英尺高的篮筐、扣篮、三分球。但话说回来，这项运动最初并没有经过精心设计。它之所以出现，真的只是因为詹姆斯·奈史密斯想阻止一些吵闹的孩子惹麻烦。整个事情始于48年前我在一个小体育馆里挂上的几个桃篮。
years ago. I guess it just goes to show what you can do if you have. I'll be right. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah That's 99% infosble for this week. This episode was a collaboration with our friends at ESPN in his part of a podcast mini-series that they're launching later this spring called Dunkumentaries. It's a collection of stories all related to basketball slam dunk. The feed is live right now so you can subscribe to it on the ESPN mobile app or on iTunes or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also find them on Twitter at Dunkumentaries for more info.
我想这正好说明了如果你有……我会马上回来。是的，是的，是的……这就是本周的《99%隐形》。本集是与我们在ESPN的朋友合作的，这是他们今年春天晚些时候推出的名为《扣篮纪录片》（Dunkumentaries）的播客迷你系列的一部分。这是一系列与篮球扣篮有关的故事。订阅源现在已经上线，所以你可以在ESPN移动应用程序、iTunes或任何你获取播客的地方订阅它。你也可以在Twitter上关注@Dunkumentaries获取更多信息。
Joe Sykes reported and produced this story with us for ESPN with help from Ryan Nantel, Emma Morgan Stern, Delina Termin, Joe Fuentes, and Kevin Wilde's. Special thanks to Jody Avergan for hooking this all up. Also check out Cari Champion's podcast Be Honest, where she has candid conversations with some of the biggest names in sports, music, and entertainment. Andrew Heisel's story in Vice inspired the idea for this story you can find a link on our website. On the 99P I-Team Katie Mingle did the heavy lifting on this one, with Sam Green's
乔·赛克斯与我们一起为ESPN报道并制作了这个故事，瑞安·南特尔、艾玛·摩根·斯特恩、德琳娜·特明、乔·富恩特斯和凯文·怀尔德斯提供了帮助。特别感谢乔迪·阿弗根促成了这一切。还要看看凯莉·钱皮恩的播客《Be Honest》，她在那里与体育、音乐和娱乐界的一些大人物进行了坦诚的对话。安德鲁·海塞尔在《Vice》上的故事激发了这个故事的灵感，你可以在我们的网站上找到链接。在99PI团队中，凯蒂·明格尔在这方面承担了繁重的工作，还有萨姆·格林、
man Avery Trouffin and Kirk Colstead Delaney Hall, Sharif Yusef and me Roman Mars. We are a production of 99% Invisible Inc, a project of KALW San Francisco, and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture in Interior's firm, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California, the one and only home of the Warriors. If you want to learn about another little game design innovation that saved the game of basketball, look for episode number 77 of this program. It's called Game Changer. It's about the shot clock. You'll like it. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us run Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links
曼·艾弗里·特鲁芬、柯克·科尔斯特德、德莱尼·霍尔、谢里夫·尤塞夫和我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是99% Invisible Inc.的制作，这是旧金山KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，勇士队唯一的家乡，由ArcSign建筑与室内设计公司的办公室制作。如果你想了解另一个拯救了篮球运动的小型游戏设计创新，请寻找本节目的第77集。它叫《游戏规则改变者》。是关于进攻时限的。你会喜欢的。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括很酷的图片和链接，
and listen to all the episodes of 99% of visible, you must go to 99pion.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。